santiago ya la ciudad está completamente
de fiesta recordemos que washington era
una ciudad que le otorgó esos tres votos
electorales que otorgaba el distrito de
columbia yo bailé en la gente ya está en
camino al centro de la ciudad
concretamente a la plaza black lives más
allá ya se convocó para ir a manifestar
el apoyo para celebrar la victoria desde
el presidente electo el presidente
número 46 de eeuu joe biden y usted lo
decía hay varios retos que afronta joe
biden ahora como presidente electo uno
de ellos la polarización es un país
completamente polarizado tron saca la
votación más alta de un contrincante en
una elección presidencial en la historia
de eeuu con más de 70 millones de votos
el reto económico es enorme el déficit
de eeuu ha crecido bastante el país está
completamente endeudado y las reformas
tributarias y las reformas para
minimizar las regulaciones de donald
trump ha hecho precisamente que ese
déficit y esa deuda crezcan también está
el reto de la pandemia
yo bailé mis un énfasis bastante
importante durante su campaña diciendo
que le va a parar bolas y va a escuchar
a los científicos para que sean los
científicos los que hablen los que
aporten las soluciones los que traten de
ponerle un freno a las cerca de 100.000
personas diarias que se contagian hoy en
eeuu por el cob it y pues obviamente eso
que usted mencionaba el reto de la
polarización y del cambio climático que
está en la agenda muy presente desde joe
biden en estos 4 años otra de las cosas
que se empieza a comentar ya en redes
sociales y con ese fin es de unir al
país es quien va a estar en el gabinete
de joe biden en estos próximos cuatro
años de gobierno algo muy importante
porque precisamente logrará unir ese
país unir ese país que en muchas en
muchos análisis que se ha hecho lo que
se dice es que el país está dividido
entre los cascos urbanos y los cascos
rurales y vemos el mapa electoral en
rojo está sobre todo esa área rural de
eeuu
ese apoyo a don autor viene de estas
partes rurales sin embargo las ciudades
principales los ángeles chicago
nueva york miami washington precisamente
y san francisco son focos de apoyo
demócrata hay que unir a ese país y ese
es precisamente el mensaje de joe barton